oh nothing but net Rob here we're taking  a look at NBA 2k more specifically the  face scan feature this time around we  gotta do things a little differently  with the phone who last year it was a  lot easier I don't know about this  iPhone stuff oh whoa  I know that guy how it's making me  fatter you're a psych loss oh my god  that left eye or my left  you're freaking out all right I don't  have cornrows  [Music]  black everyone  that's blond my ass it's because my eyes  are green they're not that's why it's  throwing it run off  [Music]  oh I mean kind of like the glasses mark  but just a part of me now  [Music]  blaming the light on this on what I have  like two sets of eyes I have my lip it's  like I have an elongated nose with lips  at my chin  I have no chin my lips are my chin  [Music]  things are meant for men so I promise  you this will not go well oh no this  isn't meant for women I'm beautiful on  the inside  this is classic it's exactly here's me  [Music]